[Music]
today is so exciting right now linus's
team is downstairs and we're going to be
doing a mac
versus pc editing challenge so we're
basically going to be going up against
each other and we're editing some of
austin evans footage
so they're gonna give us the footage we
have four hours and i don't know what's
gonna happen but they basically have
taken over my entire house so
come check it out and if you want to see
the full video i'll put a link in the
description
to linus video of this whole challenge
what i didn't know you were filming me
getting our extremely professional
paper tape set up here i have access to
all of justine's videos
yeah but they're all on the internet
yeah but i could
i could mess with them this is all held
together by tape
so hopefully it holds together hopefully
there's not an earthquake
yeah that could happen actually
this is really going to take the
pressure off it's a giant scoreboard
like
but i feel like this is how i edit
anyway because i'm like i'm posting this
video in an hour
i have to be done a half hour before it
kind of is okay let me see if i can
remember how to do this
cd set mode mode uh for
play playing
yes this looks great you are god
hey yeah why won't this computer turn on
um
because i haven't touched it yet it is
blessed now
my son we don't need it
it's not the right way to do this but
yeah holy crap that was really scary my
final cut just quit
and said it couldn't open i think it's
because i moved my motion templates
holder
what are you doing this was all working
oh god i i see the talking has begun
earlier oh look
it's working now are you still having
problems you seem to have been having
a lot of problems this whole video is
going to be you having problems
uh you know i'm just making sure
that the audio works on here and uh
obs it's like every time i open it
there's some update where things move
around
and now i don't know how to get to the
audio mixer mixer
it is it's tough i'll give them that you
know whoa
in school we learned final cut seven
that's how i that's how i learned today
you guys jaw later these are great
timers these look like
exactly like that's why i had to spend
because how
they were the only ones that were large
every other model was like this i
believe it
yeah they look really good it's really
intense honestly yeah
oh he's having butt problems
mag what is that
so how are you feeling going into the
competition i'm really excited i mean i
pretty much edit every single day so
it's just another day
taryn had some concerns about going up
against you
um in that he thought that it was going
to be
a bloodbath what what do you have to say
to that
um i mean i guess i've edited over a
billion views on my youtube
[Music]
that's plenty of time oh my goodness i
might have some extra time to eat snacks
and go to the bathroom
[Music]
honestly you know what's really funny
about that is we shot one of our highest
viewed ever videos
on an iphone really and there is one
comment out of i should i should look it
up
because it's worth having the exact
number 6.7 million views this video has
and it's got uh it's got a lot of
comments because it was very 26 000
comments
out of 26 000 comments one person was
like
hey this looks a little different was it
shot on the phone
this is too short of a chair for me
my legs hi dog
like sitting in bathroom floors parking
garages
you should you should vacate you guys
can have this banter in the next phase
this is great i'll have this banter not
when i'm editing
because it's a distraction justine i
love distractions
bye maddie this is what's gonna happen
so taryn is gonna be over here so he's
gonna be editing
over here trying to like you know do
things
so we're gonna bother him okay so you're
gonna
try and distract him with your cuteness
okay
i'm used to editing with you on my lap
so this is no problem for me what do you
want
you want your maddie replica
maddie replica sit
oh they're your friend
are you biting your friend's leg is it
i think it's unfair that he's editing
this video don't worry that's unfair
you're distracting unfair a thing that
we're trying to figure out right now
somebody doesn't like distractions okay
this is what i like to edit with i have
my phone i've got my yellow latte i also
like to have
water and i have like two different
chapsticks
okay so my dog
can i revert references okay unchecked
sound activated recording
edit preferences i knew they were like
things are behind schedule as
is common with it's okay i accounted for
this thing
we're not shooting outside yeah at least
it's kind of controlled in here i'm
actually very comfortable christine
thank you so much for having the air
conditioning your home is wonderful
it's scorching it's like 32 degrees
outside celsius what's actually
better for video editing mac or pc
which one will prevail only time will
tell
to find out we're gonna have both of you
editing a real
actual austin evans video and then the
final edit
is going to be reviewed by our panel of
celebrity judges yeah yeah
i got this i got the closet daddy's so
upset what's going on
you're so upset everybody's
do you need a water do you need some
more snacks or anything i have all my
snacks
all right thank you did you bring your
own snacks absolutely
she's not gonna
did you bring this box yes i did
it was wooden before at least i didn't
bring the wooden one so
do you want like a maybe a wait i can't
help my opponent
you can if you want do i want what this
nothing you got your laptop
with the extra screen as well
and the stream deck totally necessary
and a mouse
pad you've got a little rest yes i mean
i'm still using just editing on
you can use a mouse you want to have a
look at her setup oh yeah come around
this side
so it's literally just the macbook
that's it my trackpad
so ladies and gentlemen you're all set
up i think i'm ready green light green
light all right the last thing you need
as you so helpfully pointed out
is footage so this for each of you is
one
two ter yes you can have it is somebody
getting a little stressed over there
already
is somebody talking instead of editing i
don't swear so i don't know
it's so funny because when we edit this
down like it's gonna seem like really
like intense and you know like a lot of
stuff was happening
but this is the true you know behind the
scenes experience for a four-hour
challenge
got the lot in i've got some a-roll this
is this is definitely not how i normally
lay things out which was something that
i wasn't really thinking about
that was throwing me for a little loop
[Music]
we're 80 minutes in and justine is
taking her first
bathroom and tara apparently needs a new
chair
so i've only ever worked with justine on
camera
i've never seen her behind the scenes
like this she's
[Music]
intense
but i'm pretty sure oh my this is
absolutely incredible like you couldn't
pretty sure
no no i could not have planned this
6 25 25 3 22 21 20 10
18 17 16 15 14 13
12 11 10 9
[Music]
did i make it i think that's too close
to call it
tear and copy your file over wait he
didn't call me
update we are done editing this was
honestly so incredibly stressful and
i just had to sit here and watch this
freaking clock just tick down i also
did not know that i had to have this
completely done exported
rendered and on to a flash drive
in that four hours and i had no idea so
i'm still i'm still shaking how do you
feel about judging this content
i'm looking forward to judging this
because i believe i'm fair but also
harsh
and critical in like a wise way like you
like like i make master splinter and
yoda combined but for like
videos that's why i like to think about
myself i don't know if it's true but
you know that's the air i'll be trying
to give off in the judgment here
so are you not ready i mean i put the
judge
in judgmental so
my name means the judge literally
and i judge all the time i cannot help
it
this has been a really long drawn-out
process to find out
who is the winner are they going to
critique us like right now are we going
to hear what they think
is this now i'm not ready it's one thing
to just read it in youtube comments but
to be here in person and hear it
i can't i can't be here i don't want to
spoil anything
but even the nicest people at that table
straight brutal really yeah well they
were they were
i said look you guys are brutal and the
response was
we're here to criticize it right that's
true yeah i guess so
and they did know that we had four hours
to do this right i don't think we ever
actually mentioned that oh
really really dude
oh cool then we're gonna go through
the notes i lost the page that i wrote
them on
[Music]
breathe
we're not gonna tell you who won so i'm
gonna put a link in the description so
you guys can go and watch the full video
this was way more intense than
i thought it was gonna be yes it was it
was exhausting i have to do this next to
him too i know what that helps with
she doesn't have any apple boxes i don't
can you believe it she needs to get some
i will
okay store.com
[Music]
you